the inception of Marvel's Ironman VR all
started with the challenge
and jae-young who runs Marvel games came
back and told me that projects is
probably to go to a bigger studio and I
said hypothetically what would it take
for us to get that project he said well
that's have the best pitch I've ever
seen and a prototype that beats every
other prototype we've ever seen it time
for the heroes three years ago when we
started to prototype flight the first
thing I did was just put some physics
thrusters on your on my palms in VR
and see how it felt another looking over
to one of their employees he was in that
prototype for like 30 45 minutes just
playing it over and over and over again
just flying around in VR just like Iron
Man right and I just knew at that point
that we had nailed it so much for a
hero's welcome
we wanted to satisfy people's
expectations from that and that's not
only visuals that sound art direction
it's it's a combination of all the
senses the complexity of how the suit
animates basically and how it breaks
apart how the suit up sequence happens
have the auxiliary weapons pop out and
now it's really important to nail
visually as it's pretty much expected
the fans at this point Tony Stark as a
character is such a fun sandbox to play
in as storytellers a camouflage we
really wanted to make sure that we
paired the action with really fun and
meaningful story moments probably being
his characters in a PlayStation game but
in doing it in PlayStation VR to be
completely immersed and to be that
character and you are a ghost from your
past a lot of ways developing this game
is really really difficult but in a lot
of ways developing Marvel's Iron Man VR
is actually quite easy because when
whenever we got stuck we just look back
to the source material we look back to
what makes Tony Stark one of the most
iconic characters in the whole planet
threat neutralized good I have a plane
to catch
[Music]
PlayStation